[Music]
all right hello everyone uh I'm Josh and
today we're going to be looking at a
couple of games so the theme for today
is going to be a sicilian middle games
but that's uh kind of a misleading name
uh the only thing that these games
really have in common is that they
originate from the Sicilian Defense for
the most part
um there's there's no uh specific like
opening Theory or anything that we're
going to be looking at today but what
we're going to be talking about is uh
related to uh playing the pawn structure
and uh more importantly the tactics and
such that arise from such games so let's
take a look at the first game so the
first game today is a game where my my
good friend uh International Master
Craig Hilby is playing white and
Grandmaster resven prior to from Canada
is playing Black so let's take a look at
this game so
um
as we can see from this game we're
starting off with a sicilian night or a
very ambitious choice of opening for my
husband here and after Bishop E3 E6 we
see uh Craig's favorite move here the
move G4 so already it's a very
aggressive situation coming out in this
position so generally speaking black
prefers to open the center against this
move G4 and start off with E5 and this
is the
um
Mainline more or less involving a peace
sacrifice here there's a specific name
for this line called The Perennial
attack with a lot of theory associated
with it so in the game uh Rosman goes
for some of the uh less sharp lines with
the starting with the move H6 which is
also very reasonable uh just to prevent
the move G5 which would result in a
forced Retreat of the f69 so we have H6
Bishop G2
so it makes a lot of sense to fill out
the bishop on the long diagonal so for
example in the Sicilian one of Black's
main ways of generating counter play
would be with this move B5 but with the
bishop on G2 it is of course not
possible since E5 would create a
discovery down the lawn diagonal
so in this position the most common move
is the move Knight C6 it's just the most
played move so immediately the move
creates a powerful threat here so if you
were to Castle short for example black
is able to take on D4 and play E5
picking up the G4 Pawn so uh White plays
H3 here not an ideal move but you have
to stop the threat somehow so after H3
and so more or less white is just going
to be playing for F4 so we can see a
very aggressive setup in the case of
something like Bishop D7 for example and
there's just F4 and Mike can move the
queen somewhere perhaps to F3 followed
by long castling and white has the
makings of a good attack here and a huge
space advantage
yeah
uh yes so I was watching uh the Tata
steel coverage and I was one basically
Spindler was talking about the
shenanigan structures attack is based
this is really similar to it I'm just
kind of curious like I not that I call
every gameplay but it had not seen this
variation played in a very long time is
there it is black actually like a huge
trouble here
with the risk for black to play
um in this particular so in this
particular line it's a much it's a lot
weaker so uh okay so first of all that's
a great question so uh What uh sorry
what is your name
so what Alex is talking about here is
regarding how after five E6 the Chevy
ningan variation
um generally speaking this is not
favored at the high levels of play
nowadays because of the move G4 which we
called the carries attack
um but in this case the position is very
different and indeed black has several
ways of equalizing I believe this line
ends up in some Force draw at some point
which is why for the most part people
don't really play the move G4 G4 is is
definitely not the main move in this
position but the position that was
reached in the game this position is um
so in the uh analogous line here for
example after G4 black here has to play
H6 and then white usually follows up
with some combination of Rook G1 and H4
with an immediate uh pressure on G5 but
in the game here this is not really
feasible
so like for example the the inclusion of
the moves A6 and Bishop E3 is very
useful to Black here if white were to
play something like H4 does that make
sense yeah okay so after H6 Bishop G2
yeah so uh White's just preparing to
play F4 so we have Knight C6 into H3 so
uh black decides to prevent white from
making this King side and Central
expansion and goes for the move Knight
E5 which has an active idea so now uh
White is already at a bit of a
Crossroads so clearly the idea for black
is to meet the move F4 with Knight C4
um
whether or not this is a huge disaster
or something like that is uh not up to
me to decide but uh so like for example
I have to F4 Knight C4 uh
white would have to play Bishop C1 but
this is actually not a huge problem for
white uh since it's fairly easy to
remove the Knight with B3 on the next
move so uh if black were to play
something like Queen B6 B3 E5 would now
be forced and perhaps white is doing
fine in this position
um so after Bishop C1 it's also possible
for black to play E5 and attempt to
capture on F4
um but after Queen D4 it looks like
white is going to be having some
pressure here since that Knight and F5
is super strong my friend even had the
uh consideration to write the note here
that uh against G6 white should strongly
consider ignoring the threat
so also possible is Queen E2 which also
makes a lot of sense so in this case if
black were to play something like Queen
C7 then after F4 Knight C4 uh the plan
for white here is going to be giving up
the dark Square Bishop with long
castling and uh hopefully in this
position white would have the makings of
a strong attack even without the bishop
pair
but in the game white decided to Castle
and maintain some more flexibility so
now in the case of Knight C4 Bishop C1
is probably even better than the
variation with F4 since black doesn't
have any E5 Associated counter play so
we have short castling and G5 so G5
sometimes looks a little bit strange In
the Sicilian but makes a ton of sense
here since black really does not want to
let white to play F4 and therefore black
is going to be looking at making some
pressure on the dark squares and keeping
that Knight on E5 so if we notice here
this is a pretty typical situation from
the Hedgehog structures where the nylon
E5 is super duper strong here since
white is not going to be able to play F4
so
of course it is possible for white to
play F4 but this is not really a
dangerous situation for black uh it
looks a little bit uh shaky for black
since the files on the king side are all
open and the black king on E8 has some
potential to be loose but this mountain
E5 basically just stops everything by
itself and it's going to be quite a
hassle to trade off
so in the game we see Queen E2 which
makes a lot of sense and now black
continues with Knight fd7 perhaps Bishop
E7 is a little bit more accurate with
the plan of playing H5
and it seems that this is a pretty tough
situation for white perhaps the white
should simply capture the g-pawn and if
white were to try to maintain the pawn
structure like this with playing F4
Queen H4 is extremely annoying so
perhaps this is a better plan for black
but 957 also makes a ton of sense uh
just making sure the Knight on E5 is not
going anywhere and maintaining some
flexibility with the bishop since black
is not 100 sure whether it's E7 or G7
direction is more appropriate just yet
so this is a good point to stop and uh
take stock of the situation so we know
that uh black has a super solid position
in the center and the center is very
closed so it's actually a little bit
difficult to come up with a plan here so
uh in this position the computer thinks
that white is slightly better but in a
position like this which is very Dynamic
and open there's not really this doesn't
really mean too much neither side has
any obvious weaknesses or anything like
this so uh one thing we can determine is
that black has excellent control of the
dark squares especially the E5 and F4
squares which are going to be very
difficult for white to challenge
so the big question mark for black is
regarding the king safety since the king
side is completely open and of course we
don't want to leave the king in the
center forever so it makes a lot of
sense for black to go for a plan
involving uh perhaps a B6 Bishop B7
Queen C7 and long castling so if black
could have uh unlimited time this is
what black would do and from there black
would have an excellent position so
uh it's a little bit hard for white to
make a plan so one plan is to attack the
D6 Pawn which is the only really serious
weakness in Black's position but at the
same time it is very difficult to
arrange the minor pieces in such a way
to do so that Knight on E5 is extremely
powerful and uh so the main
consideration for white over the next
couple of moves is going to be whether
or not playing F4 is good so
F4 has the positive benefit of opening
up the f file but it's not entirely
clear how beneficial this is since uh F7
is pretty well protected it's going to
be really difficult to pressure again
thanks to that beautiful not an E5 but
and opening the G file could actually
potentially be dangerous for white so my
friend decided to do here is make the
very smart choice of Simply playing Rook
81 and thinking about it on the next
move
so F4 is possible here and it is
probably true that uh
that this is the best move for white in
the position since uh now on Bishop E7
white is going to be able to play Rook
af1 in a single move which is better
than uh so The Rook is better on F1 than
D1
and um yeah but even here it's not 100
obvious that this position is so bad for
black and indeed this position can lead
to some highly unclear sacrifices
so
but in the game Rook 81 is completely
fine so in this position we have uh B6
so black does not want to play B5 in
this type of situation because let's
keep in mind that black sorry
we can keep in mind that black is going
to be looking for Queen side castling so
black does not want to allow white the
option of opening up the a file with
something like A4
so B6 played in the game oh fairly
standard so
in this position there are many
different plans for white and here we're
going to be talking about one of the
main points of the lecture today is
formulating a plan so uh unfortunately
the the last uh think which resulted in
Rook 81 has not been help has not helped
white in the biggest of ways so all of
the white pieces seem to be pretty well
placed so here it's time to make an
active plan so there are a couple of
active plans here so uh Alex what's one
plan that you can see here for white
I'm looking at ideas
there's the possibility of playing
you have this in your back pocket Maybe
Hayward
sorry
a4a5 and if you takes you might ever be
on board over the queen side I think
it's between side
uh
I guess you can move the knife or
uh to put pressure on D6 and maybe turn
the pressure on B6 with the original I'm
not sure the combine that with a485
I don't know something like that yeah
there's definitely a lot going on here
so the principal plan here for white or
I should even say principled plan for
for white here is to play F4 and
recapture an F4 with the bishop so doing
so would undermine the would help to
undermine the noun of E5 and in this
case The Rook on D1 is actually very
useful since it is pressuring D6 and the
D file by association so that would be
one key idea here to play F4 recapture
with the bishop and follow up with
Knight F3 in order to uh in order to put
pressure on E5 so at this point it's
already possible for white to play F4
but there actually are several other
plans so
uh one plan that I find really
interesting personally is the idea of
putting a pawn in C4 which would help
White's position considerably especially
knowing that black is going to be
castling long opponent C4 would really
help white to undermine the queen Side
by way of a4a5 which is currently not
such a great idea because black will
always close the queen side with B5
against that move so
um so B3 is actually a really
interesting plan with the idea in
association of Queen D2 92 and C4 which
is not such a bad plant so and the third
plan is to begin with Knight F3 and
trade the pair of knights and then
continue with F4 so these are three
possible plans so let's just take a look
what happens so F4 is I believe the
favored plan of the computer and it's
probably what I would have done myself
after Knight F3 Queen C7 takes takes
Queen F2
against Bishop G7 white can even
consider rerouting the knight from C3
where it's not doing so much to the G3
and therefore H5 which would create some
issues for black in this position so uh
yeah it looks like F4 is a pretty good
move
Knight F3 is also possible and in this
position it's going to be possible for
white to either play F4 or even continue
with Bishop D4 with the idea of slowly
improving the position with B3 and queen
E3
so yeah several options here and uh the
B3 plan is one that I like although it's
not actually the best plan
this position should be roughly equal
but I think that uh
I think that this is this is a very
interesting plan since I'm not 100 sure
what where exactly black is going to be
looking for counter play
um perhaps it's not the best plan since
the original position we're going to be
looking at where the black king is uh
uh super weak in the center and so we
want to be playing aggressively but uh
it's very important that in this case uh
we know what we're doing as white and
that's really important
so in the game uh my friend decided to
continue with the fourth plan which is
Knight of five
so 905 is a really interesting move so
the move looks visually to be very
appealing the move is uh one it's a very
typical move where it looks like we're
sacrificing in peace and we're going to
be crashing through very shortly
so move Knight F5
um
makes a lot of sense so if black was to
take on F5 then after he takes out five
the light script Bishop would come alive
the D5 Square becomes weak and all white
species seem to come to life in exchange
for that piece so it seems to make a
whole lot of sense
the problem is that the move Knight F5
doesn't actually have a very convincing
plan attached to it so of course white
is immediately creating the threat to D6
which results in two major candidate
moves for black he takes F5 and the
other being Queen C7
so we already established that e takes
F5
um even without evaluating whether or
not this is good or bad for white we can
already tell
that this position gives White's
position a lot more play so and what
about the other move Queen C7 well it
turns out that after Queen C7 there's
not really any special benefit to having
the Knight on F5 so after Queen C7 the
idea of this move Knight F5 is to shift
the Knight to H5 with Knight G3 but at
the same time
I'm not entirely sure why it is so
important for for white to actually
achieve this right not an H5 looks very
pretty visually since it cannot be
harassed by enemy pawns and therefore
occupies an important Outpost but uh
doesn't really contribute much to the
rest of the game I mean after all we all
we always say that Knights on the rim
are dim and such and such
um
so yeah definitely not the most uh
impressive plan but the reason we're
looking at this game today is because
black actually did in fact take on F5 so
etix F5 is believe it or not the best
move according to the computer so e
takes F5 is the best move theoretically
but the problem is that in this position
white doesn't really have any play
following Queen z7 there is no special
plan for white and so therefore e takes
out five doesn't really make a whole lot
of sense since in practice you don't
want to be giving your opponent play
when they don't have any so far
so after he takes F5 my friend writes
the note which is very well worded here
and peace here is a small price to pay
for a clear plan and an untack on an
undeveloped Army so we have e takes F5
he takes F5 Rook V8
oh that's a great question so I think
that both moves are are very appropriate
and lead to double-edged positions
um
it depends I personally would be scared
to play e65 under any circumstances
and I think that what I would do is I
would probably look for an alternative
very early on and once I realized after
Queen C7 white is going to be playing
Knight G3 then I'd be very happy with
that already so probably I would make
this decision fairly quickly probably I
wouldn't spend too much time on it since
uh after he takes up if we just look at
this position really quick we can tell
that uh well I don't know if this is
good or bad like if I was playing a game
like I would have no idea whether this
was good or bad for me but I think it's
already clear to me that it's not
something I would rather have does that
answer your question yeah I'm just kind
of curious
you always risk it and accept the
material and try and fight on or you
know like if you're not doing such
things are you playing the wrong
thing
a couple of strong players I've seen
recently who have been surprised
surprise prices they just they don't
accept them and then they play on and
have a cat a casual draw
anyway
yeah I think it just depends on the on
the on the specific position
um yeah I mean the thing is that like
here it's not so much that like I'm I'm
really afraid of like getting checkmated
immediately I mean obviously it's very
dangerous but I mean if we just look at
black Central peace placement it's very
solid so I'm not really too afraid of
being checkmated immediately but just
looking at this position I can see that
the white light Square Bishop is very
weak the White Knight on C3 contributes
very little and the White Knight going
to H5 I'm not particularly scared of
either so I basically just like my
position here I think that the computer
evaluates as equal because it's also
quite difficult for black to do
something but I think in a practical
game I would already have a preference
for playing black and therefore I would
probably just play Queen C7 without too
much thinking
so
after e takes F5 e takes F5 Rook B8 so
now white wants to open the center so of
course White follows with F4 and fawn
takes F4 Bishop takes F4 so now black is
at a critical moment so most of Black's
obvious moves here have something wrong
with them like for example
um a move like Bishop E7 which is very
uh positionally desirable right
um would allow white to win the game
pretty much immediately let's move F6
and Bishop takes F6 is met by Knight E4
and Knight takes D6 is going to be
completely decisive
the other move that uh seems very
desirable for black is Bishop B7 but the
problem Bishop B7 is that after it takes
takes the a pawn is hanging and after
Queen takes A6
um so it's not that this Pawn uh like
just makes white and win the game
instantly or something white is still
down a piece but white is definitely
going to be having enough compensation
for the material with two pawns rather
than one so after Queen takes B5 I mean
if the black pawns were anywhere else it
could perhaps be possible but black has
four pawns and four distinct Pawn
islands and therefore this is definitely
not what black wants to be doing
I guess the way to think about this in a
game setting is that from here the best
case scenario here doesn't even seem
like a win since uh the pawns are too
split to meaningfully create past Pawns
in any sort of ending so uh so in this
position black has a lot of things to
think about since as we stated before
most of Black's obvious moves have a
serious drawback to them already so in
this position uh what I think is the
best practical move is uh B5 so this
move looks very odd but the main problem
but the main point of this move is to
protect the A6 Pawn so that Bishop B7
becomes possible so it's very
positionally desirable for white to go
for something like 925 but the move
actually doesn't achieve anything since
nylon D5 doesn't attack any meaningful
points so after Bishop B7 black is going
to be able to solidify the position here
after removing the Knight on D5
so if white were to continue with
something like Rook D2 which also makes
a lot of sense so it's possible for
black to play Bishop B7 here but even F6
is possible to delay it for a couple
moves and now a black can even choose to
support D6 fully with Rook B6 and return
some extra material here and Black's two
pieces here are going to be outweighing
the rook in the near future
the best move rated by the computer is
the move F6 which looks very different
but in fact the black is just going to
play B5 next move and there's no special
difference here
so in the game black decides you go for
something a lot more ambitious with
Queen C7
unfortunately too much more ambitious so
Queen C7 obviously black is uh pretty
much baiting for for Knight D5 since it
just seems very obvious here for for
white to bring the Knight to D5 it's a
beautiful centralized Square it can't be
attacked by any pawns and threatens
Black's Queen so my friend decides to
oblige that with Knight B5 with Knight
D5
and here we can see the uh idea of Queen
C7 although uh just between you and me I
think I would not play Queen C7
regardless of anything this move is just
so scary to play so Black's idea was to
follow up with Queen C5 and then Queen
C4 so this is the point behind Queen
Seven it looks incredibly odd but if
white is to move the queen with
something like Queen F2 or actually it
doesn't really matter where the queen
goes after Bishop B7 B3 and queen C8
black has succeeded in playing the move
Bishop B7 with uh with only uh Tempe
moves in between so uh black will be
able to trade off some pieces and
probably reach a preferable position
since once the Knight is gone it's going
to get very difficult for white to
threaten the dark squares in a serious
manner
so after Queen C4 so white needs to act
very quickly since black is basically
one move away from consolidating
everything
so the right move and probably what
preo2 had overlooked in anticipation is
the move Rook D3
so my friend has a pretty funny thing
here where he says that uh black wants
to a bishop B7 next we even have the C8
Square for his Queen so after some time
I found myself wishing for a rook on the
C file and uh therefore this move popped
into my head so after Rook D3 uh black
has an issue where pretty much all the
black's serious moves have a a problem
with them so for example uh Knight takes
D3 C takes D3 and wherever black moves
the queen
um let's say queen takes A2 white is
simply going to be playing Bishop D4 and
uh The h8 Rook is going to be
disappearing from the board very soon
even after 95 Bishop takes E5 and white
is completely winning in this position
oh yes
Bishop G5
so Bishop G5 is possible based on the
idea Knight 3 E5 loses to Queen takes C4
and then Knight C7 but the problem is
that after Knight 75 Knight F6 King d8
there is unbelievably there is no
discovered check and therefore black is
winning in this position
or okay I shouldn't say there was no
discover check but there's no uh
meaningfully useful discovered check
especially since the G5 Bishop is
actually hanging in this position so
black is time to consolidate and win the
game with his extra rook and a knight
so yeah but good question
um that is a that would be a fun way to
Checkmate if that actually happened
so the other obvious move for black is
Bishop B7 since well that was the idea
of Black's previous move but now that
the Rook is on D3
um white can simply meet Queen with Rook
C3 and the game should be over since uh
Queen d8 is met with Knight C7 which is
not acceptable for black and Knight C5
is met by uh simply B4 and once black
loses the Knight he will find himself
without any form of compensation for the
uh very uh weak King and poor minor
pieces
so here I think black made an excellent
practical decision so um I think most
likely I can't read his mind of course
but I think most likely black had uh
missed the move Rook D3 and so in this
position what I think black did was
calculate a few moves the obvious for a
few minutes maybe the obvious move
tonight takes D3 and Bishop B7 and
realized that both of them are losing
and so most positionally desirable Moons
for black that aren't those two such as
Bishop G7
will result in a queen trap following B3
where Queen C6 could even be met by a
knight F6 or something like this and
white is going to be having an excellent
position here
so he decided to play Queen takes A2 and
complicate things
so indeed it's actually really annoying
here for White 2 uh trap of Black's
Queen which is the most obvious plan
given that the queen is on A2 and the
black king on E8 is very weak meaning
that some minor pieces are very
difficult to bring into the game so
let's take a second here and let's look
at what white should do to uh pressure
the two Targets on E8 and A2
AAR on YouTube says you're stuck in the
center probably busted fast yeah that's
definitely what it seems like for the
for the record the reason I think that
black uh missed Rook D3 was because I
really don't think black would have
played Queen C7 if the idea was to
capture the A2 Pawn that that doesn't
seem very uh principled to me uh
although maybe that's just me
so uh for dessert on Twitch seems to
have the right idea here with move
Bishop D4 so Bishop D4 does two things
um so the first threat which is
mentioned in the associated twitch
comment is to play B3 and Rook A1 in
order to capture the queen on A2 and so
this seems very slow and that is
absolutely correct this is an extremely
slow plan
but white has another threat with the
move Bishop D4 the threat funnily enough
although it might be a bit hard to
believe is actually to more or less just
Checkmate right away so in the case of
the move Bishop B7 or something like
this which actually does address the B3
threat then white has the beautiful move
Bishop takes E5 Knight takes E5 and a
queen sacrifice Queen takes E5 D5 Knight
C7 and then F6 is checkmate
so Bishop D4 wins immediately since any
move black can play that addresses the
bishop takes E5 threat is going to lose
to the B3 threat so king d8 would lose
to B3 and after Knight D3 Queen D3 black
is doing relatively fine materially
after uh
after Rook A1 appears on the board but
the position itself is completely lost
the black king is horrible and All
Blacks pieces I mean if we just look at
the black piece then look at the white
pieces it's not even close and uh yeah
it's it won't uh won't be sufficient for
black
um so yeah it's very tough situation for
black indeed
um DM on YouTube says what about King d8
instead of Queen takes A2 perhaps this
is possible and perhaps better but black
remains in a very tough situation since
after B3 or perhaps several other moves
are viable but B3 just looks the most
obvious to me the black queen will need
to go somewhere it really does not want
to go such as C6 and then perhaps even
Rook C3 is very dangerous for black so
yeah after Queen takes A2 so Bishop D4
would win the game immediately but this
game would have gone down as a pretty
quick miniature and probably not one I
would be lecturing at today if Bishop D4
had indeed happened in the game
so the other thing is that it is
actually possible for white to trap the
queen immediately and by force with the
Moon Knight C7 but black actually picks
up way too much material in this case
but I can either take an A3 straight
away or provoke C3 and just take an A3
and take nc7 and this is just way too
many pieces here the two knights and The
Rook are definitely a match for the
queen here mostly because the black king
is now relatively safe with the C file
closed
so Bishop D4 is definitely the best move
another strong move here is Rook B3
which also has the idea of driving the
queen with something like Knight B4
Knight C3 but in the game My friend
decided to go for a night before which
also looks very tempting so the idea
here is to bring the Knight to C6 and it
looks very pretty
so after night before so black has a
couple of squares with the queen queen
takes B2 would simply allow Queen trap
with Rook B3 so that is not acceptable
for black
so the two moves for black here that
makes sense are queen A4 and queen C4 so
in the case of Queen C4
um unfortunately this move uh
results in some pretty unfortunate
things for black after Knight C6
so if black moves The Rook then B3 is
going to be trapping The Black Queen
very shortly and if black takes the
Knight I can interject the move Bishop
D5 and this is actually a pretty amazing
case where the black queen is actually
completely trapped since any move to a
dark Square will result in its loss from
the Discover check from the bishop move
such as Queen A5 Bishop D2
so black goes for Queen A4 in the game
and uh so here we have a really
interesting situation so the most
obvious move in this position for white
is Knight C6 which my which is actually
turns out to not be the best move
although the lines after the best move
Rook F4 are very difficult to navigate
so after Queen B5 is necessary for y to
sacrifice The Rook on D3 and in this
position uh White is down the entire
Rook but the attack does not stop
um
since Bishop D4 check is an insanely
powerful threat and so is Knight C7
black is pretty much forced to play King
d8 and white has two tempting
continuations here uh the most natural
one is probably Bishop D4 which is
actually the weaker one and uh so it's
very important here for black to play
Rook H7 and not Rook G8 which just goes
to show how uh how ridiculous these
lines are
so in the case of Rook G8 black loses to
B4 with the threat of Knight C3 again
very obvious I'm sure
so before and so black should try to
evacuate the queen with A5 but after
Queen C2
um yeah black it just ends up losing
here so for example uh another uh pretty
ridiculous line Knight C5 loses to
Bishop F6 followed by Queen A2 with the
threat of Knight C3 and capturing the F7
Pawn so Mitch black is not going to be
able to defend again because the Rook is
not on H7
so
uh now with black wants to protect for
The Rook B7 then after Rook E4 uh
there's Maiden 2 with the threat of
Queen takes C8 and Rook E8 the order
does not matter funnily enough so uh
after so black is forced to defend the
background with Bishop G7 but after
Bishop takes G7 it is not possible for
black to capture on G7 again because of
Queen takes C8 with a fast Checkmate so
black was gonna have to eliminate the
Knight and drop the queen to rookie 8
after which white is just winning
so it is very important for black to
start with Rook H7 after B4 now black
has the option of saving the Queen by
not saving the queen with the wonderful
move F6 Knight C3 rookie seven
so in this case after Queen C2 Queen
takes B4 now Bishop takes F6 is not
possible because it is not check so
uh in this case why would have to play
Knight D5 but now the black king is able
to run away through F7 and black more or
less is surviving here you can pick up
the rook and even pick up another Knight
but that is only enough to equalize
material and black ends up being fine in
this position
so pretty amazing stuff
um unfortunately for for black even if
you saw that you would still end up
losing to Rook before
Queen A5 Queen C2
and yeah the central problem for black
is that uh in the case of Knight C5 you
will be hanging the F6 Square which is
not okay and uh yeah this attack is
crushing once The Rook lands on e4
so the only way for black to
appropriately Evacuate the appropriately
defend the C7 Square would be through B5
with the queen
and again another very unobvious uh and
very hard to see uh finish with Rook F4
uh the reason this is such a strange
move is because Rook E4 actually is not
sufficient in view of Bishop G7 B4 Queen
A1 so The Rook needs to go to F4 to
threaten B4 and beat Queen A1 with Rook
F1
so black would be forced to play B4 in
this position or to prevent B4 and then
white can pick up the queen to Bishop B6
and after big C4 uh White just has a big
Advantage here although black has two
pieces and a rook the placement of those
black pieces is very bad for the
situation
so anyway so in the game we have um
Knight C6 instead which is a much more
obvious move and I don't think the lines
after book F4 are humanly plausible so
we have Knight C6
so again because of the way the pieces
are positioned much more so than the
fact that the Rook is hanging on B8
um just white cannot be allowed to keep
the Knight on C6
so um after the night is on C6
um
black is pretty much forced to take on
C6 it is possible for black to take on
D3 but in this position the Discover
check with Bishop D4 is not going to be
manageable
so we have Knight takes C6
and then this bishop takes C6 Queen C6
and for those of you familiar with the
Opera gameplay by Paul Murphy the move
Bishop G5 should stand out since uh 95
is the only possible move
and after a queen takes E5 check black
is not going to be able to recapture
that Queen on E5 so definitely
understandable why uh why white would be
tempted by such a continuation so after
Queen takes the E5 check King D7 is the
only move here which my friend actually
had not seen was legal since Bishop E6
uh
fails in several different ways I think
F takes E6 is the funniest way since the
since capturing the queen would lose to
e takes F7 Checkmate
um
but after uh
yeah after uh Queen takes h8 white is
also just completely winning so not okay
for black
so King D7
so after King D7 there are a couple of
things that are not going too well for
white so first of all the most obvious
move for white would be to capture The
Rook on h8 but unfortunately black is
not going to capture on G5 and allow the
loss of the f8 bishop black will start
with uh Bishop B7 so after Bishop B7 the
threat of Checkmate means that white
does not have time to capture well the
bishop is now protected and white does
not have time to save the bishop so
after something like Rook F3 H takes G5
black would actually be winning here on
account of the extra material
so it's very important here for white to
not lose track and continue with Queen
F6
so H takes G5 Queen takes F7
and in the case of Bishop E7 black would
end up uh with a loss here after Rook E8
and F6 so uh yeah unfortunately black
just doesn't have time to make any
meaningful threats against the white
king so white will be able to capture
the bishop and then be winning from
there
so black is pretty much forced to allow
a Perpetual check here which white
decides to repeat the move position one
time which is I think a really clever
decision uh definitely if you have the
option in this type of situation where
you have the attack for a very long time
it's very good to repeat the move the
position one time just to a gain some
time on the clock since time usually
benefits the attacker and number two to
psychologically mess with your opponent
because he will probably be very happy
to make a draw so after Queen F6
oh yes
so I've heard I heard such advice before
is there any I've never heard anyone
talk about like
quickly you should repeat like should
you give any thought
you know a minute or two between the
repetition like if you're going for a
maximum psychological effect like
um personally I I would never uh I would
just repeat instantly but that's what I
would do
um because uh I mean like I remember
reading in an augard book at one point
that uh uh that you should give him a
few checks to tell him who's boss and
that's pretty much how it goes uh is
pretty much because you because whenever
you repeat the position you show your
opponent that you have control right
like that you can that you can repeat if
you want and if you don't want to repeat
you don't have to right so uh what my
friend was actually not probably not
intending to to repeat the position uh I
would have if I was white in the case of
King D7 I would have just played Queen
F7 and uh here I would play Queen F6 but
it's also possible for white to play
Rook C3 and reach a really unclear
position here after capturing The Rook
um but personally I find this really
scary with white my king is very exposed
and the black light Square Bishop coming
to the long tag was something I don't
really want to to allow basically
so I would have just repeated moves but
that position is also fine and unclear
King C7 loses to Simply Rook C3
so um
but in the game black plays definitely a
bit overzealously with Bishop E7 to hang
The h8 Rook with check so yeah probably
not uh probably not Black's best
decision but uh as we will as we will
later see this works out very well for
black in the game so we have Queen takes
h8
and uh so the computer wants to play
Queen E8 and play on this losing ending
but uh I think that uh if I was black I
would definitely not play Bishop E7 if
that was my intention so uh we see King
D7 in the game
and so black is currently threatening
the move Bishop B7 so it is up to White
to uh prevent that since that would
create a double attack on the queen and
uh Queen G2 checkmate
so for example F6 uh it's very tempting
move but uh loses instantly to Bishop B7
um and the move Rook E1 is very tempting
since now on Bishop B7 there is Rook
takes E7 check and white is going to be
winning here uh after a queen G7 check
essentially the the winning uh theme for
white is going to be to uh bring the
queen to E6 at some point and then uh
capture on uh well and then Forest Rook
C3 which would win the queen so that
would be the winning Motif in that case
but unfortunately for white black can
flip the move order around and start
with Queen G2 check after which black is
going to have a pretty good position
here in this endgame after book takes h8
so the key for white is to start by
preventing Bishop B7 with the move Rook
ff3 so if we remember that the C8 Bishop
is currently pent and the four Bishop B7
would simply Drop The Rook on B8 so
after Rook F3
um in this case white is now threatening
Rook D3 with ideas of F6 or Rook takes
E7 so it moved like Queen takes C2 for
example would lose to Rook D3
and after check Rook takes E7 is winning
for white since eventually black will
have to allow a Checkmate here
so black goes for D5 to prevent this so
now Rook E3 uh White is going to play
Bishop C5 and in this position white has
many different ways to reach a winning
position
so for example
um
probably these the simplest one is is to
start with Rook takes D5 and play Rook
D3 although for me this is the probably
the least obvious one to tell that
White's winning but after picking up the
G5 Pawn most likely the game is going to
conclude by uh White using two pawns to
win the bishop and keeping an extra one
and uh winning the game with the queen
and pawn versus Brooke and Bishop so
that should be winning for white
although probably the least clear one uh
Queen E5 I think is definitely the best
move here
um because the double attack on the rook
and the D5 Pawn is very uncomfortable
for black so after check King F1 uh
Bishop D6 white can win in several ways
but probably the simplest is just roll
the F Pawn so that should be winning for
white
um even F6 is winning for white although
this is definitely not what I would want
to do this ends up being winning since
the uh f8 square is a little bit uh
um hard to cover for black and B4 is
also a serious threat uh Peter from
YouTube yeah I'm sorry about the uh Pace
earlier
um the problem was the thing is like
those tactical lines don't really matter
so I'm just trying to go through them
really quickly they don't really uh add
or take away from the themes of the game
and I think that pretty much applies to
uh
um to pretty much any like lecture on
chess I think that like for the most
part like long computer analysis is
really just not important to
understanding uh pretty much any lecture
but yeah this is definitely one of the
tougher games that that's for sure
um
so yeah so anyway so in this position uh
my friend decided to uh play a
move that well this is this would
probably be the best move if black
didn't have the continuation that he
does but uh Queen G7 so it looks like
the threat of F6 is Unstoppable and
indeed if white is allowed to play F6
then white will simply win the game
since the f-pawn will roll and the uh
Bishop on E7 will not be able to escape
but unfortunately black is able to just
completely hang the D5 Pawn with move
Queen F6
foreign
so after Queen F6
um unfortunately I think that uh my
friend became very frustrated with
himself for not seeing this move so um
what you should do if this happens in a
game so you see yourself with a loss of
momentum so um
so after so for example after Rook takes
D5 and queen takes F6 the position here
looks very uncomfortable for both sides
I always say jokingly that I would lose
this position with both colors which is
probably true
um
but the position uh in reality the
position is about equal but definitely
very unclear and three results are
absolutely possible but again just a few
moves ago we were completely winning to
the tune of plus five or plus six so
definitely doesn't feel very comfortable
um so I think what happened here was
that my friend was really frustrated and
uh wasn't sure like what to do here and
so uh what often happens here is that
people who are in this situation they
think well okay I was winning so I have
to win and um so therefore it's really
hard to that's why it's so hard to play
when you lose the momentum and you go
from the attacking side to the uh
defending side
so in this position what you should do
is if you have time which I believe my
friend did what you're supposed to do is
you're supposed to get up go to the
bathroom wash your face
um and uh try to switch the momentum
back and try to look at the position
objectively so objectively white should
do this white should take on D5 and then
take an F6 and then reach this very
bizarre end game
unfortunately what white does is uh well
it goes through the thought process well
I had a winning attack just before I
used to keep the Queens on and so
continues with Queen G8 so in this
position black is able to achieve an
advantage here by starting with Bishop
C5 and then playing D4 and with the
center closed
the chances of white having an advantage
are extremely small
since the black king is now safe and
black should have a great position here
instead black makes the somewhat
careless move d4 I'm guessing that uh
the most likely black wasn't facing some
foreign time trouble so in this position
black is able to force a draw with the
move white sorry white is able to force
to draw with Queen C4 so the problem for
black is that the D4 Pawn is not
defendable since Bishop C5 is met by B4
so uh black is most likely forced to
play King E8 to defend the D4 upon so
now there is a bishop C5 pin that is
available but in this case white is able
to repeat moves with Queen G8 and King
D7 has Queen C4
so again this is possible to do but my
friend was still in the mindset that he
is should be attacking so he ended up
going for Rook fe3 so if we read his
note I thought for like 10 seconds
before playing this I just saw the
threat of Rook E6 and figured this was a
good move of course I was just taking
terrible moves out of frustration again
so uh obviously this is not like a
thought process you can have when you're
playing the game like I thought for 10
seconds and I just saw rookie six and
this has to be good like that uh that's
not a that's not exactly a winning
formula there but it's very
understandable like I'm sure it happens
to to everyone to think like this
sometimes right
so we see rook fe3 and now uh black can
just simply protect the E6 square with
King C7
and uh yeah very quickly white loses the
thread and then ends up in a really bad
position here after Bishop D7
so now we can see on move 34 black
finally develops his last piece and the
threat of Bishop B5 is very strong so uh
B4 is not possible since the bishop B5
would just simply pick up too much
material
so white ends up going for Queen takes
A6 but now black has completely
Consolidated and white is the one with
the weaker King in the saddest Twist of
them all so in the the game actually
ends with Queen B5
and which is not the best move because
it allows white play to gain some
counter play with Queen D5 but white
ended up going for a queen F7
and after Queen takes B2 it's a little
bit sad but the white Rooks are simply
just weaker than the black bishops and
are not able to enter the game
so we see Queen tank C2 Queen takes D3
and um yeah sadly enough the black
bishops are just exerting too much
pressure and my friend actually resigned
here since the position is completely
losing
so very very sad game for for white
white played very inspiredly uh had some
excellent tactics in the middle game
starting with Rook D3 but uh yeah very
very sad situation to to loose but you
know that's just how it happens when you
have a really sharp game with three
results that's just uh the type of
situation that ends up happening
sometimes so uh my friend even wrote
down a list of lessons to take from this
game so it's very important to so first
of all in this opening it's okay to let
the Knight come to C4 and take on E3 so
the key here is that the time is more
important than the uh Bishop in this
case
um and uh move 13 so we can go back to
move 13 real quick
to do right so here so this move Knight
F5 I think is a really indestructive
Point here
so basically what ends up happening is
that white is not able to come up with a
plan even though several good ones exist
in the position but
um
Knight F5 just is a move that just looks
tempting and therefore is played but
perhaps not the not the best in terms of
formulating a plan so it's important to
remember that just because your
sacrifices work doesn't mean that you
should actually play them so yeah that's
a good thing to take away here
um
and uh yeah it's really important to uh
make sure that you close out the game
when you have your advantage and uh such
as with on move 20 so we can go back to
move 20.
um
so yeah the move Bishop D4 here uh
really important move as well so it's
really important to close it out and
bring all your pieces in when the game
is when the end of the game is close at
hand
and uh yeah one thing I really want to
bring to mind for the students here is
uh
regarding this decision here with uh
quinciate I think that this is probably
the main Turning Point the truth is that
white is not exactly lost after Queen G8
but uh the the move indicates a uh poor
mindset which is what ended up in uh
White losing the game
okay
um so I do have some other games ready
for today but I I don't think that we'll
have
time in seven or eight minutes right so
uh do you think it's worth starting
another one or
yeah I mean the other games are
definitely shorter than this one but uh
uh in uh
what do you guys think in the audience
okay all right so uh audience the live
audience here uh seems to really want to
do some more so let's go all right so uh
let's okay not this game let's do this
game so this is a game where I'm playing
Black against uh Jack Peters who is an I
am in the Los Angeles area he's pretty
well known around there actually he was
um he was actually the chess columnist
in the LA times for a time for a period
of time
so uh in this game I'm playing Black so
let's flip the board to the black side
since my side is the one that matters so
we have E4 C5 Knight F3 E6 D4 takes
takes and A6
so this is the Sicilian con which I may
have mentioned before is my favorite
opening and has been one of my if not my
only main opening for black for the last
uh 10 years or so
so after A6 we see Bishop D3 which is
one of the most common responses
oh yes
sorry don't mean to put you on the spot
I've heard I've heard some other GMS
that have come by that just will talk
about how they believe the cons like
nearly reviewed it are you like
I get you would contest that right like
that's not
oh I mean so I think refuted is a is a
really strong word do I think it's like
the the best way for for like do I think
it's like the the objectively best way
to play the silly and probably not
otherwise the engines would would play
that way
um but there's nothing like particularly
wrong with it obviously I've analyzed it
in uh in in great detail uh I don't
think that it's like losing or anything
I think that white has some chances to
achieve a very small Advantage if white
plays absolutely perfectly
um which I don't think is a serious
problem in general right I mean we are
playing black and uh more importantly
this is an opening that uh it's very
ambitious for black there are very few
peace trades
um and black is setting up a very solid
Pawn structure and therefore it's an
opening that is primarily being used
when for me at least now in my career
when I'm trying to win the game which uh
therefore means that I'm willing to top
it a little bit more risk so for example
I did play this way when I had to win as
black against
um
in the last round of the U.S open we
eventually Drew but I was winning for a
big portion of the game so yeah clearly
I think it's I think it's at the very
least I think it's viable at uh at all
levels of human play
um in correspondence people do some
weird things but nobody has really
proven a serious advantage in
correspondence either for the record the
main move in correspondence chess
against uh
in this position is the move A3 so that
should give you a idea of the level
where we're talking about here but black
is fine in all lines uh is my impression
or relatively fine at least
perhaps there are some positions you can
say are preferable for whites but uh
that's not a that that's just that's
just how it goes with the territory I
mean you would say that the Berlin is
preferable for white at some point right
so that's just how it is
all right so anyway so let's just look
at this game so we have Bishop D3 so
Bishop D3 is one of the most common
moves here since uh basically white is
not committing whether the pawn should
stay on C2 or go to C4 so uh so it's
very flexible move and then so for black
um uh Bishop C5 is a pretty natural move
to take advantage of the drawback of
this so Knight on D4 is uh loose who
sends Bishop D3 interferes with its
defense and forces white to go to the
inferior square with Knight B3
I no longer like the assistant with
Bishop E7 very much but this is a really
common idea in the Sicilian to kick the
knight from D4 when it is not being
protected sometimes Bishop Z5 sometimes
Queen B6 sometimes Knight C6 but the
idea Remains the Same
so we have Queen G4 G6 and so this is
what most people play against the con
these days oh sorry against this bishop
E7 setup nowadays I probably prefer
Bishop A7 in the US Open of last year I
made draws with both Vladimir acopian
and the po4 mentioned Daniel neraditsky
from that position
so I had to Bishop E7 we have Queen G4
G6 yeah not not a very fortunate move
for black to play but the other way is
to protect G7 I'll have some problems
with them so G6 I'd C3 and so uh pretty
quickly we end up in this very standard
position after B6 and F4
so after F4
um so the the problem for black is that
the move Knight gf6 is usually met by
Bishop H6 with a white preventing black
from castling and this is the drawback
of the early move G6 so after B6 F4 now
Bishop H6 is no longer possible so
Knight gf6 arrives and so the key point
in this game I want to be talking about
these specific moves are not really so
important but the specific point I want
to talk about is resulting is regarding
this position so at first it appears
that uh Black Knight on H5 is completely
out of the game and you would be
absolutely correct this not an H5 has
basically no hope of rejoining the
position which is sad but you know
necessary evil and all that so the point
here is that the nanon H5 does an
excellent job of
um
there's not an HIV does an excellent job
of inhibiting White's attack so if the
Knight was not present on H5 uh White
would be able to play h4h5 himself and
the opening of the H5 would almost
certainly prove decisive so the Knight
has no Mobility but it is able to uh but
here on H5 it does a very important job
here and in order to make any progress
on the king side at all black will more
or less white will more or less be
forced to exchange it off and this is
possible to do but at the same time
white will need to rearrange the minor
pieces in an unfortunate way and with
White castled Queen side the main action
for black is going to be on the queen
side anyway so not an H5 being in such
an immobile place is not such a big
hindrance so we see B5 so with black we
want to be attacking on the queen side
we have two queen C7 and then Knight E2
so the idea here for white pretty
clearly is going to be Knight G3 trying
to exchange that on H5 which would be
very problematic for me so
on this position
um I decided to go for Knight C5
so immediately there's a threat of
Knight takes D3 followed by capturing
the pawn in E4
as well as just immediately captured
upon E4 of course
so we see Queen H4 to protect that u4
pawn and after Rook C8 white has to make
a big Choice since uh Knight takes D3 is
very serious threat and white is no
longer able to play the normal defense
of recapturing with uh pawn and D3 since
Queen C2 is able to pick up the Knight
on E2
so in the game we have Knight takes C5 D
takes C5 and yeah it looks very odd here
but in this position Black's attack is
the one that arrives first so
um what white should do is white should
play C3 but after C4 Bishop C2 black can
do a bunch of things here including B4
and yeah I'm definitely not convinced
that white has the preferable position
here given that Black's attack it seems
to be coming quite quickly
so in the game we have Knight G3 which
again as we talked about before is the
most natural move to attack H5 but
unfortunately for white uh White is just
a little bit too slow and after C4
Bishop E2
the uh attack for black crashes through
with C3
so after so in this position white is
not going to be able to take an H5 since
he takes B2 uh just checkmates on C2
basically
so white is forced to go for B3 and I
imagine that my opponent was rather
looking forward to meeting with Queen A5
with King B1 when there's no way forward
since Queen A3 is met with uh Bishop C1
so the key for black here is that uh
both sides have this sort of weird Pawn
structure but since I'm the one with the
Knight on H5 I'm actually cannot really
be checkmated on G7 or at the very least
it will take white a bunch of moves to
do so so I'm the person who has the
stronger dark Square control and
therefore I should exchange the Bishops
with Bishop C5
and so after Bishop C5 ux D3 takes takes
in this position black is just simply
winning since the skewer here it's not
so much that this gear wins material
since Knight F1 is possible but the
threat of Queen A3 is uh much too
serious for black to for white to ignore
so Queen A3 is already possible but
white still does have the thread to
Bishop takes H5 so it's somewhat
important to be careful here so I
started with rookie d8 and the threat of
Queen A3 is well in this case it just
immediately checked mates so white again
does not have time to play Bishop takes
H5 and instead has to go for this very
sad move Bishop D3 so we can see how the
last two moves white has taken both of
his pieces off the Knight on H5 and used
them to defend which is fine but uh
means that as black you are pretty much
certainly not going to lose this game
so after Rook takes D3
um so the skewer now comes into effect
since after Rook takes D3 Queen takes G1
is winning for black
and C takes D3 gets checkmated by Queen
A3 uh well perhaps Checkmate it is
strong but I think after I make another
queen I won't have too many problems
winning the game so uh we just simply
have B4 which is the definitely the best
try for white here but if we just take a
look at the white pieces we can see that
there is pretty much no way white it's
going to be able to survive this attack
so uh in the game we have Rook D7 uh it
doesn't really matter what white does at
this point uh the thread of Queen B2 is
uh pretty much not stoppable so we have
Rook D7 Queen B2 and uh in a very sad
Twist of situations uh after Bishop F3
white is not going to be able to defend
the maiden 2 with Knight G3 since that
on H5 is controlling that square
so uh in this position uh and queen F2
is track committed by Queen C1 so in
this position my opponent decided to let
himself he mated with Queen D4 and queen
E2
so yeah hopefully uh these games uh were
able to Showcase some uh ideas uh and
how to play Such Pawn structures with uh
in this wonderful Hedgehog structure
okay I think that's all I have for today
thank you guys so much for tuning in and
uh yeah I'll see you next time
[Music]